welcome to exploring computing
today's video is bits bytes and binary
part four in which we learn how to
represent egyptian hieroglyphs on a
computer
so so far we've concentrated on how to
represent
numbers on a computer but many of you
listening to
this video are probably people who spend
more time
typing and writing than you do
calculating so
i like to switch gears here and talk a
little bit about how we can represent
text on a computer we talked briefly a
couple videos ago about how
different combinations of bits might be
used to represent
different things like the state or
province that somebody might live in
or the dorm that somebody might live in
and so
a natural way of thinking about this is
we can represent text
by using different character
combinations
and by the way if you hear some whining
in the background that is my dog maddy
she's all psyched and excited and wants
to know why i'm not playing with her
anyway what i'm going to show you next
is something called the ascii table
this is the ascii table you can see that
what we're seeing here is that different
combinations
of bits can be used to represent
different
specific letters or numbers or even
punctuation on the computer let's take a
closer look and see how this is done
so in the upper right hand corner of the
ascii table we can see
here we have the representations for a b
c d
e and f both upper and lower case
suppose
the computer were to see the bit
combination one
zero zero zero zero zero one or
on off off off off off on
we can see that this would actually be
representing the capital letter a
in contrast if it were to see this
particular bit sequence
one one zero zero one zero one or
on on off off on off on
it actually represents the lowercase
letter e
now i should caution you that these
particular interpretations of these bit
patterns is only true for computer
programs which are designed to work with
text
remember a particular sequence of bits
can represent different things depending
on what the particular program that's
looking at these bits is designed to
work with let's take a closer look at
our original bit pattern for the letter
a
one zero zero zero zero zero one as
we've seen
if we're working with a program that
works with text such as a word processor
this will be interpreted as the letter a
however if we're working with a
different program
say a program that's designed to work
with numbers this could actually be
interpreted as the number 65.
why well let's take a quick look at the
math here
so we've got our eight bits here
starting on the right
our zero bit this represents two to the
zero power
which is one and then next to that we
have our two to the first power
which is 2 or 2 to the second which is 4
or 2 to the third which is 8.
we've got 16 32 and 64. so
if we look at this we have 1 2 to the
0th power which is 1
and 1 2 to the sixth power which is 64
and so we have a total of 65.
i think it is important when we're
looking at these bits to remember that
at one level as far as the computer is
concerned bits are just bits
the thing that determines how those bits
are interpreted is the program that is
working with them
as long as a program that is working
with these particular bits
is thinking of them as ascii then what
it will be interpreted is
is the letter a there are other possible
interpretations
it could be a number it could be a sound
it could be part of a picture
but in this particular case we're going
to assume that our program knows that
this is an ascii
character and so it looks it up in the
ascii table and displays
it as an a let's take another look at
the ascii table here
i want to focus on the left hand column
now now if you look at the left-hand
column you'll notice that the left-hand
column actually has
punctuation marks and the numbers 0
through 9 when they're represented as
part of a text document
now we focus on the the upper left
corner here
of this table you'll notice something a
little bit odd about the uh
about the numbers here if you look
carefully you'll notice that
our upper left-hand column does not
start off with the number
zero instead you can see that it starts
off with a zero one
zero zero zero zero zero this will be
even more obvious if we go ahead and
switch this
to decimal you can see here that the
codes representing the ascii characters
start off with the number 32
and go up to 127. why does it start off
with 32
what happens below the number 32 well it
turns out that there's a whole
another set of codes going from 0 to 31
which represent what are called the
control codes
if you look at the corner of a keyboard
particularly windows keyboard
or a unix keyboard you'll see that
there's a control key and by holding
down that control key and typing
different characters
we create different control characters
this next table here shows you some of
the
more interesting control characters so
you can see that
for example the control h character
represents the backspace
the control m represents the carriage
return
and you can see that some of these were
originally used for back in the day when
we had teletype
which was basically a typewriter that
was connected to the computer
and in this particular case the control
g which i've always been rather fond of
uh would actually ring a bell and for
quite some time if you were working in a
text editor you hit the control g
your computer would actually ring a bell
was actually kind of cool but i'm afraid
i haven't run into any text editors
lately that do that
but the basic idea here is these
different control characters
allow us to transmit control information
using the same ascii character set one
of the other aspects of the control
characters that you will sometimes run
into
is that the computer manufacturers did
not agree on what the correct character
to use for the end of a line was unix
computers
microsoft windows and pre os x
macintoshes all use different characters
to indicate the end of line the main two
characters involved here are ctrl
m which stands for character turn and
control j which is
line feed historically the control j
line feed would
take the piece of paper currently in the
teletype and it would shift up
that tele type by one line and the
control
m would return the printing cartridge
from wherever it was currently on the
line and return it back to the start of
the line
microsoft windows assumes that you need
to perform both operations you need to
perform a control j operation to shift
down to the next line
and you need to perform a control m to
move to the start of the current line
unix just uses the line feed it just
uses a control j
and pre-osx macintosh just used the
character term or the control m
this can lead to odd situations so i've
seen editors where
a standard text file written on one
operating system
you open it on a different operating
system it looks like garbage let's take
a look at
how this might work on the top here we
have a text file that's been created on
the macintosh and when viewed on the
macintosh
we've got the line stanford university
followed by the control-m
which is the pre-osx macintosh version
of the end of line
followed by computer science and on the
bottom here what we see is
how this might appear on a pc text
editor so what we've got is we've got
the stanford university as before
and then we've got the control m which
is a character turn and on the pc that
just returns
to the beginning of the line it does not
shift down a line and so we actually
have here is that
we have stanford university and
immediately on top of it
computer science fortunately most modern
editors are conversant enough
on the various possible ways of ending a
line
that they will do the translation for us
that said
most high-end text editors particularly
those designed for programmers will
allow us to set which
convention we want to use so this image
here shows the settings for
sublime in the top left notepad plus
plus on the right and visual studio code
on the bottom and you can see these all
have options for deciding whether we
want to use
the unix convention the windows pc
convention and in some cases
the pre-osx macintosh conventions
another place where this distinction
between
how we're going to represent the end of
line for these different operating
systems shows up is
when we're using file transfer programs
now file transfer programs
distinguish between text files and
binary and so one of the questions is
why do we have this distinction and so
we're seeing here is this is secure ftp
this is a program that stanford
recommends for transferring files
for windows computers to say the
stanford
unix machines and you can see that
secure fx is asking me
if i want to treat a particular file as
a text file or a binary file
why does it need to know the difference
between these two don't we just transfer
each of the individual bits and bytes
over and then our file transfers done
but what it's actually asking here is
it's saying if this is a text file
it is going to go through the text file
and look for each of these end of line
sequences
and it's going to convert from whatever
it sees in the file
for example if it's going to say oh i
see that you're using the windows
convention or i see that you're using
the macintosh convention
and it's going to look at the computer
i'm transferring it to say oh you're
transferring to a unix computer so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to take the
convention that's
being used by the computer that you're
transferring from and i'm going to
convert
those end-of-line characters to the
proper sequence for the computer that
you are transferring to
let's go back to that ascii table if you
look carefully at the ascii table
you may realize a couple things the
first thing that you may notice is that
there are only seven bits for each of
our characters
and as you know computers generally work
with sets of eight bits
or a byte and so that actually means
there's a whole bunch of combinations
there that we're not taking advantage of
we're only taking advantage of two to
the seventh possible combinations
or hard 28 combinations when if we have
a full byte we actually have 256
combinations
the other thing you may realize is that
this is a very english-centric table
here
you know even looking just at europe
there's a whole bunch of different
characters we need for european
languages that aren't listed there and
obviously
there are a whole bunch of other
languages that aren't european and they
don't have characters
listed at all and so how are we going to
handle this
well one of the things that we can do is
we can take advantage of
the fact that we do have 256
combinations in a byte
we can say oh 128 of those are set aside
for the english characters
and the remaining higher 28 we can use
for different purposes and so this is
what a standard called iso 8859 does
there's a number of related iso 8859
standard so you can see here i've got a
list where
iso 88591 represents western european
characters you see i've got some samples
there
two eccentric european three is south
european
and so on we've got arabic we've got
greek we've got hebrew
and there are a whole bunch of these
other sets and these all work with
languages where we can fit all the the
letters needed for the language in 256
characters
the way this particular standard works
is one we have to tell the computer
program
which one of these character sets are we
using are we using the arabic character
set
are we using hebrew character set are we
using a cyrillic character set
which one of these are we using the next
thing we need to do is we need to look
at our eight bits here
and you can see i've got i've got seven
of the lower end bits are one one zero
one zero one zero
and then if the high end bit is a zero
that means i'm using the standard ascii
table and this would actually be a j
if the high end character is a 1 that
means i'm using iso 8859
and then the particular character would
represent would depend on whether i'm
using iso 88591
2 3 and so on and so here are some of
the possible interpretations of
what this particular bit sequence means
based on the particular iso character
set i'm using
now we do need to have the iso character
set correctly
so what i've got here is i've got a web
page i've written in french
and you can see as i change the
character set being used
for example if i don't correctly tell
the web browser which character set to
use and
it thinks that oh this is cyrillic or
this is arab or this is greek
you can see that the web page is going
to appear differently and incorrectly
now what about non-western languages
well there are a number of different
standards for these as well
and most of these use 16 bits so
into in 16 bits we can represent two to
the 16 different characters
which we'll call 65 536
and that's going to be enough to
represent most of the characters and say
for example chinese although
there are probably going to be some
ancient and not very frequently used
characters that
that aren't going to fit in our 65 536
so these are going to be used for
different languages
um that don't fit in 2 to the 8th
combinations
and again we need to have a program that
understands them
we need the program to understand the
particular character that's
set that's being used this is a copy of
harry potter and the philosopher's stone
that i got from the pottermore website
i was learning japanese and
on the far right we can see that these
are the names of the chapters in
japanese and what we have on the left is
well we basically got garbage what
happened here is that
when i got the files from pottermore i
downloaded them to my pc which was
expecting
characters that were only eight bits
long and
the characters used by the pottermore
files were 16 and my computer did not
know what to do with them so
it basically turned the names of the
files into garbage
so the problem we're seeing here is that
different
bit combinations represent different
things depending upon the particular
encoding
so we can have the one character
combination that represents
an e in english and the same character
combination
might represent a tsu in
japanese so what we need is we need a
more
unified system and it turns out there
actually is a more unified system
unicode uses between one and four bytes
per character and if you do the math
two to the 32 possible combinations
because there are 32 different bits
in four bytes allows for four billion
two hundred ninety four
million nine hundred sixty seven
thousand two hundred ninety six
combinations
so that's a heck of a lot of
combinations and not only does
unicode allow us to store all the
different languages that we've already
seen
it also has bit combinations which will
allow us to represent
ancient languages like egyptian
hieroglyphs sumerian cuneiform
and even mycenaean linear b which we
have seen but we don't actually know how
to read
it also includes things like music kill
characters and emoji
so we're going to do is we're going to
take a quick look at how you might use
this unicode in
for example a history document so let's
say i'm writing a
history paper and i need to use egyptian
hieroglyphs in my history playbook
the first thing i need to do is i need
to get a hold of a font that
can display egyptian hieroglyphs so
remember
unicode only specifies the particular
bit sequences to represent these and it
guarantees that
there's a unique bit sequence that for
my egyptian hieroglyphs that can't be
confused with say
chinese characters or korean hangul
or english letters so every single one
of these
different marks that human beings make
in order to
represent language has a unique bit
combination and they can't be confused
one for the other
that being said that doesn't mean that
every
font has every possible one of these
four billion combinations worked out so
it knows how to draw it so for example
if you used times new roman
times new roman is designed for english
and european languages it is not
designed to show
mycenaean linear b so you know if we
were to see that
bit combination for a massinian linear b
character in times new roman times
neuron would be like i don't know what
that is so
i'm just going to draw a block so you
will often see
either blocks or little diamonds with
question marks in them
these are different indications that the
font that you are using
understands that there's this unique bit
pattern but it does not actually have
the ability to display that unique bed
pattern so the first thing we need to do
if we want to write our
paper with egyptian hieroglyphs here is
we need to go ahead and find a font that
supports egyptian hieroglyphs so
you know you can just go to google
google egyptian
hieroglyphs unicode font and you will
get a bunch of different hits
i chose one that was supported by the
open font license so i could go ahead
and use it for our class
there are many many more choices if
you're just using it for personal use
um and it turns out google actually has
a bunch of fonts for
things like egyptian hieroglyphs or
sumerian
cuneiform or machine linear b and so
those are actually the ones that i'm
using here for this lecture okay so we
need to go ahead and download that font
and we need to install on our computer
and the process for that is going to
vary depending on the type of computer
you have
the next thing we're going to do is
we're going to find out
what the particular bit pattern that we
want to use
for the particular character we want to
reproduce in our paper so
we can look up a table uh turns out
wikipedia has
tables for many of the different
languages supported by unicode so here's
the table here on
wikipedia for egyptian hieroglyphs
unicode
and what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to look at the the column on the
left
and i'm going to look at the rows on the
left and i'm going to look at the
columns on the top and i'm going to
combine those two in order to
form a unique number now these are
actually in
hexadecimal this is a numbering system
that's very closely related to binary
you can think of it as a very compact
form of binary
we'll take a closer look at this in more
detail uh another week
i think you know one numbering system
for the week is enough so we're just
going to
stick to our binary for this week but
another week we'll take a closer look at
hexadecimal but these are hexadecimal
here
so i'm going to figure out what the
hexadecimal number is from this table
then i'm going to go ahead and go to
microsoft word i'm going to set the font
because again remember if i use one of
the standard fonts like
ariel or helvetica they don't actually
have drawings for egyptian characters in
them so i need to switch to my
font that has egyptian characters in it
and then i'm going to insert
symbol this is how microsoft word will
allow you to
insert any unicode character so switch
to the insert tab
and on the far right there's insert
symbol and go ahead and click all the
way down to the bottom where it says
more symbols and that will go ahead and
bring up a dialog box
and i'm going to go ahead and enter in
that unicode code from
the table on wikipedia i'm going to go
ahead and enter that into the dialog
box and then that's just going to go
ahead and insert my
egyptian character there in my document
so there you go i'm all set i now know
how to
enter egyptian hieroglyphs on the
computer so now that we've taken a look
at how the computer represents some
basic data types
in the next couple lectures we're going
to turn to some more complex types of
data we're going to start off by taking
a look at how computers represent
images this lecture is going to be
useful if you're planning to shop for a
new computer or
a new television we'll discuss the
underlying technology and the
terminology
and it's also going to be very useful if
you're planning to create
any sort of digital imagery and you need
to know what the correct tools and what
the proper formats to store your files
in
are after that we're going to take a
look at how computers represent music
and sound
and between the digital images and the
sound lecture we're going to
take a closer look at the critical
difference in a critical understanding
of
the difference between digital and
analog i look forward to talking with
you all again soon
you